[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour vivre le temps fort de la semaine
parlementaire la reprise des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est à suivre en exclusivité et en
intégralité sur public sénat et au
sommaire de cette émission 45 minutes
des changes direct entre les sénateurs
et le gouvernement nous allons tout
analyser tout commenté avec nos
journalistes alice bardot dans
l'hémicycle et alexandre poussa qui
recueille pour nous toutes les réactions
dans la salle des conférences à tout à
l'heure le gouvernement renonce à son
projet de réduire une aide pour les
seniors destiné à l'emploi à domicile
les explications d'edouard philippe dans
un instant et toutes les réactions au
sénat enfin nouvelle journée de
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites un texte qui provoque une
levée de boucliers alors qu'il n'est
même pas encore écrit qu'en disent les
sénateurs on voit ça tout à l'heure et
n'hésitez pas à réagir et à commenter
toute cette émission avec le hashtag qu
âgées
[Musique]
je vous le disais en titre le
gouvernement renonce à supprimer
l'exonération fiscale accordée aux
seniors de plus de 70 ans qui emploie
une aide à domicile une mesure contestée
jusque dans les rangs de la majorité
présidentielle on écoutait les
explications des premiers ministres
edouard philippe prend tout de suite la
direction de la salle des conférences
avec vous alexandre pousse à vous êtes
avec patrick kanner le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat alors est-ce
que ce recul d'edouard philippe le
satisfait avec pioneer qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de ce rétropédalage
d'edouard philippe sur ce coup de rabot
fiscal qui visait les seniors à d'autres
époques on aurait appelé ça un grand
couac en tout cas une grande cacophonie
gouvernementale
on peut pas comme ça prendre en otage
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
âgées qui font appel à l'aide à domicile
une situation qui est pour moi ubuesque
à savoir que manifestement cette mesure
était inscrite dans le marbre du budget
qui va nous est présenté en tout cas on
l'espère un jour à venir par le
gouvernement et d'un coup de rabot
inverse il ya 350 millions de dépenses
fiscales qui disparaissent au vite
qu'elles sont apparues donc moi je suis
très inquiet sur cette méthode de
travail et puis je vais vous dire les
personnes âgées de ce pays nous
retraités ont déjà subi la hausse de la
csg sur les retraites le gel de leur
retraite donc ça ne peut pas être la
variable d'ajustement des mauvais choix
budgétaires du gouvernement parce que
vous avez le sentiment qu emmanuel
macron mène une politique anti seniors
en tout cas il mène une politique au
doigt mouillé et manifestement c'est lui
qui a dû siffler la fin de la récréation
de l'assemblée générale de l'onu où il a
d'autres bien d'autres chats à fouetter
manifestement donc une situation que je
qualifierais de d'imprévision par le
gouvernement attention de ne pas sinon
désespère les français en tout cas les
prendre pour des gens qui ne
comprendraient pas aujourd'hui les
enjeux de ce pays et dire hier soir
qu'on allait supprimer cette exonération
fiscale et la remettre aujourd'hui en
place en pleine questions d'actualité
dénonçant son ministre du travail madame
pénicaud monsieur
edouard philippe devrait quand même
regarder un petit peu comme en fonction
de son gouvernement est hors du coup
cette mesure était censé faire des
économies des centaines de millions
d'euros économisés comment on comment on
fait pour combler les trous a déjà c'est
une mauvaise mesure rappelons le par ce
que ce horaires et encourager le travail
au noir très concrètement et serait
supprimé des milliers des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois qualifiés non
délocalisables et utile pour les
personnes âgées donc comment faire j'ai
envie dire j'attends la réponse du
gouvernement aujourd'hui et je crois que
c'est une première en france nous
n'avons aucun élément sur les grands
équilibres budgétaires de ce pays alors
que dans trois jours on nous présente la
maquette ou va-t-on c'est une vraie
question qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui
très bien merci patrick kanner pour
votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre on vous
retrouve tout au long de cette émission
autres sujets conflictuels les retraites
après les professions libérales la ratp
force ouvrière c'est aujourd'hui la cgt
qui défilent contre la future réforme
pourtant le gouvernement temporise sur
ce texte au sénat à droite comme à
gauche on demande à l'exécutif de lait
coûte face à cette contestation
béatrice 15 ans avec sandra cerqueira
urgences environnementales et sociales
après le 20 septembre nouvelle
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites cette fois ci alors que
matignon a multiplié début septembre les
rencontres avec les partenaires sociaux
la cgt en tête du cortège dénoncent un
projet de réforme qui fragiliserait les
pensions ayé plus longtemps pour gagner
moins ça c'est le mot d'ordre du
gouvernement ici c'est travailler moins
longtemps et avoir une pension qui
permettent de vivre donc nous le savez
nous sommes pour le retour à la retraite
à 60 ans nous sommes pour un seuil
minimum de pension de 75 pour cent vingt
smig à 1800 euros alors que dans la rue
la grogne contre l'exécutif continue du
côté des parlementaires même constat il
faut écouter et réagir l'opinion shirai
s'impatiente elle exprime scheer et
parfois dans des attitudes assez
violentes sont dans l'incompréhension
devant la capacité des autorités
publiques à maîtriser les enjeux de
demain les enjeux de demain mais dès à
présent
à droite aussi on s'impatiente face à
une réforme qui traînent aux enfants de
report en report on sait plus très bien
ce que le gouvernement parce que quand
même à près de 18 mois de discussions et
négociations par jean paul delevoye on
nous dit qu'on a ré ouvert plus d'un an
de discussions donc on sait plus
d'ailleurs quand est ce que fait cette
réforme des retraites on nous dit
normalement début 2025 imaginez avec
convergence de 2025 à 2040 pour moi le
déluge la loi sur la réforme des
retraites devrait être présenté avant
l'été 2020 prochain rendez vous à la fin
du mois emmanuel macron doit lancer une
grande concertation citoyenne
place à présent au premier texte débattu
en cette rentrée le projet de loi sur
l'économie circulaire et contre le
gaspillage un texte qui déçoit les
sénateurs une mesure focalise
l'attention et la polémique la consigne
pour les bouteilles en plastique
explications de louis du mesnil
je crois qu'il faut à tout texte de loi
son objet transitionnel son symbole eh
bien peut-être que dans ce projet de loi
ce sera la consigne ce devait être la
tête d'affiche du projet de loi anti
gaspillage la consigne en sera
finalement le point de crispation
examiné par la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire le texte a
laissé les sénateurs sur leur faim la
secrétaire d'état avait pour objectif de
mettre en place la consigne d'ici la fin
du quinquennat une consigne qui
s'appliquera uniquement aux bouteilles
en plastique recyclable un non sens
écologique pour le président de la
commission alors qu'il faut mettre en
place des solutions pour cesser ce tout
plastique en l'ancré dans cette consigne
ont relégitime la bouteille plastique et
séduire par hasard c'est un certain
nombre d'industriels au premier rang
desquels coca cola sont absolument à
fond pour cette mesure bien mais peut
mieux faire voilà ce qui ressort de cet
examen le projet a été retoqué le
gouvernement voulait élargir le concept
de pollueur-payeur aux producteurs de
jouer de tabac et de matériaux de
bricolage les sénateurs eux vont plus
loin et vise les fabricants de textiles
sanitaires comme des serviettes
hygiéniques et les couches qui
représente 33 kg de déchets non
recyclables par an et par habitant le
volet environnemental laisse à désiré en
fait on est en deçà de ce que nous
sommes en mesure d'attendre d'un texte
qui a été annoncé comme quand même un
grand texte de l'acte 2 du quinquennat
parmi les autres retouches faire payer
les producteurs de déchets pour financer
la lutte contre les décharges sauvages
calqué sur les objectifs européens le
projet de loi a mis le cap sur 100 % de
plastique recyclé en 2025 contre 50%
aujourd'hui
c'est donc un texte qui suscite bien des
crispations entre le sénat et le
gouvernement à ce que ça se confirme
dans l'hémicycle on va tout de suite
rejoindre alice bardot le texte est
débattu depuis une heure et demie qu'est
ce qu'il en est oui tu aimes les
discussions ont commencé sans surprise
la consigne s'est invitée au coeur des
débats alors rappelez vous la consigne
c'est ce dispositif qui existait jusque
dans les années 90 pour les bouteilles
en verre alors les élus locaux sont
dubitatifs ils déplorent un dispositif
flou mais pas que et écouter martha de
sidra clara porter l ère du texte
notre commission a largement exprimé le
regret que le recul environnementale que
constitue la con si telle qu'elle était
envisagée dans le texte initial viennent
éclipser les avancées de votre projet de
loi comme l'interdiction de la
destruction des invendus ou encore la
création de nouvelles filières rep en
effet vous avez vous même fait de la
consigne madame la ministre le symbole
de votre texte alors que le dispositif
de consignes pour recyclage sur les
bouteilles en plastique envisagée par le
gouvernement nous paraît au contraire au
mieux anecdotique au pire à rebours des
véritables défis environnementaux du 21e
siècle la ministre brune poirson assure
que cela se fera en accord et en
partenariat donc avec les collectivités
territoriales
écoutez là
il y a des grands industriels de
l'agroalimentaire qui vont alliance avec
la grande distribution et qui installe
des systèmes de consigne en vase clos
sans en parler aux élus sans en parler
aux collectivités locales est ce le
système mais vous avez raison monsieur
le sénateur ne laissons pas faire
absolument nous ne laissons pas faire
travaillons ensemble pour faire en sorte
que ça ne soit pas possible en france
travaillons ensemble pour lisser au
coeur au coeur du système de gestion des
déchets en france les collectivités nos
collectivités il reste donc trois jours
aux sénateurs et aux gouvernements pour
travailler ensemble puisque l'examen du
texte durera jusqu'à vendredi
merci merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes
ces explications avant de revenir dans
l'hémicycle ont fait un détour par new
york à l'assemblée générale des nations
unies ou greta tanberg à hyères frapper
fort
l'icône démarches pour le climat a
dénoncé en larmes l'inaction des états
dont la france une leçon qui a bien
crispé emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement les sénateurs eux sont
partagés flora sauvage
elle accuse les dirigeants mondiaux de
trahison dans un discours à la tribune
de l'onu lundi
great attenberg la militante suédoise
pour l'environnement a tenu un discours
poignant tout en indiquant avoir déposé
plainte contre la france et quatre
autres pays devant le comité des droits
de l'enfant de l'onu au sénat le
discours de la jeune femme ne laisse pas
indifférent sa démarche me dérange
beaucoup pour la bonne raison c'est
qu'une jeune fille de son âge doit être
à l'école et non à faire du sit in its
ou là on se rend bien compte que
l'impact de différentes problématiques
que l'on rencontre et qui sont dénoncés
par cette jeune kial qui n'a que 16 ans
quand nous étions pelé tous emmanuel
macron a rapidement répondu à greta
tanberg dénonçant des positions très
radicales tout en incitant les jeunes à
aller manifester en pologne un état qui
bloque les avancées de l'union
européenne sur le réchauffement
climatique
on a besoin de la mobilisation
moi j'y suis très sensible elle m'a
aussi bousculé et fait changer mais
maintenant il faut qu'elle se porte plus
sur c est ce qu'on doit faire bouger
encore davantage je ne stigmatise
personne mais je veux convaincre nos
amis polonais que c'est bon pour eux de
bouger mais chez les sénateurs
socialistes le discours d' emmanuel
macron dérange aujourd'hui un double
discours sur la défense de la transition
écologique juste qu'on a un président
qui s'expriment beaucoup sur le sujet
mais qui en décalage total avec les
décisions politiques qu'il prend au plan
au plan national pour avancer au niveau
national emmanuel macron veut se doter
d'un budget vert qui tracera recettes et
dépenses en fonction de leur effet sur
l'environnement une mesure qui devrait
être intégrée dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 et en prolonge sur
cette thématique en rejoignant alexandre
poussard salle des conférences vous êtes
avec jean françois husson c'est l'un des
écologistes de droite dessena oui jean
françois husson la jeune great attenberg
un peu bousculé hier à l'onu emmanuel
macron notamment sur l'inaction
climatique de la france qui est ce que
vous avez pensé de cet échange entre les
deux je pense qu'effectivement la france
n'agit pas assez mais ce qui me
préoccupe aussi c'est de voir finalement
cette jeunesse manifester appeler à
l'aide et aux secours et peut-être
l'insuffisante prise en compte par les
acteurs institutionnels les politiques
bien sûr mais également le monde
économique des travaux du giec et d'un
certain nombre de grands experts
scientifiques ça c'est un vrai sujet et
je crois que pour la planète il ya
vraiment urgence à agir et urgence à
agir ensemble
c'est ça qui est le plus important et
donc l'idée n'est pas où le plus
important n'est pas de savoir si cette
jeune fille je dirais c'est plus ou
moins bien exprimer il faut regarder au
delà faut regarder avec les yeux de
l'avenir de notre planète notre escale a
raison de porter plainte contre la
france qui est un des pays qui est quand
même assez engagé sur la question
climatique je pense que là il ya plus
que des trous dans la raquette on peut
quand même se poser des questions sur
quelques-uns des grands émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre contre lesquels il n'y
a pas d'action n'ya pas de plainte c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il
faut remettre de l'objectivité de la
vérité dans les débats par contre ça
nécessite me semble-t-il une vraie prise
en compte à la fois mondiale mais
peut-être plus encore
pour nous français et européens la
france a une place à jouer là rôle
particulier à jouer elle est à l'origine
de la construction européenne et je
crois que l'europe doit aujourd'hui
s'engager pleinement pour le climat
c'est un continent qui a des enjeux
importants on l'a vu cet été ça fait
plusieurs années où on a un certain
nombre de grands experts on a des grands
sommets je crois qu'il faut vraiment
rock reprendre une longueur d'avancé et
amener les acteurs les habitants bien
sûr mais l'ensemble des acteurs
institutionnels la banque et la finance
doivent être aujourd'hui pleinement
mobilisée en faveur du climat sur tous
ces jeunes qui sont mobilisés en faveur
du climat qui marchent tous les
vendredis emmanuel macron of les a
qualifié de sympathique mais finalement
que leur marche n'allait pas régler le
problème il les a même invités à aller
manifester en pologne est ce que ces
petites phrases sont judicieuses son jeu
je crois qu'il faut il faut surtout pas
balayer d'un revers de main il faut
avoir aucune forme de mépris moi ce qui
m'importe c'est à la fois que ces jeunes
manifestent est finalement secoue nos
habitudes réveille nos consciences mais
vous savez je suis aussi frappé par une
chose pour les livres sur le terrain
toutes les générations même les plus
âgés sont aujourd'hui préoccupés parce
qu'elle regarde les sources ici qui
s'assèchent et les cours d'eau qui ont
un filet d'eau là où il y avait beaucoup
plus à ben de débit très bien merci
beaucoup jean françois husson pour votre
réaction et on va tout de suite allé
dans l'hémicycle et rejoindre ma
collègue alice bardot qui va nous
présenter le menu de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec
notamment des questions sur le
renoncement du gouvernement à ce coup de
rabot fiscal contre les seniors et oui
alexandre au programme des questions au
gouvernement donc cole la suppression de
l'exonération fiscale accordée aux
personnes âgées non dépendantes lorsqu
elle emploie une aide à domicile edouard
philippe a annoncé donc l'abandon du
projet tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
nationale
plusieurs sénateurs ont prévu donc
d'interroger le gouvernement à ce sujet
il en sera donc question tout à leur
autre sujet brûlant dans l'actualité
l'immigration un débat parlementaire est
prévu à l'assemblée nationale le 30
septembre prochain et tout de suite donc
le début des questions au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues mme à
cette question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics mais je vois qu'elle s'adresse à
madame muriel pénicaud madame la
ministre le gouvernement semble
poursuivre sans relâche un objectif
baisser le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
il y a eu la hausse de la csg il y a eu
la sous- indexation des retraites et
maintenant ce sont les déductions
fiscales accordées aux personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans qui emploie une aide à
domicile qui sont dans le collimateur
décidément la personne âgée bien mal
menée par ce gouvernement
river les personnes âgées des moyens qui
leur permettent d'être accompagnés dans
leur vie quotidienne
et est une double erreur à laquelle vous
allez sans doute nous confirmer que vous
allez renoncer
d'abord parce que le vieillissement de
la population appelle des réponses
multiples et le rapport libos comme le
mien du reste ont démontré s'il en était
besoin que le maintien à domicile reste
une priorité absolue pour le bien-être
des personnes âgées et pour l'équilibré
des finances publiques
ce projet était aussi une faute parce
que faire des retraités les nouveaux
boucs émissaires n'est pas digne
les personnes âgées méritent notre
respect vous ne devez pas vous ne pouvez
pas les considérer comme une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire il a été annoncé
que vous reculiez sur la suppression des
avantages fiscaux qui concernait les
aides à domicile
c'est du reste conforme à ce que
monsieur d'arman avait déclaré sur rmc
le 6 février dernier à l'époque il
n'était pas favorable à ce que
d'éventuelles suppressions de niches
fiscales touche les emplois à domicile
et on ne pouvait qu'être d'accord
j'espère madame la ministre que cet
épisode de va et vient pdt le peu
glorieux pour le gouvernement va nous
éclairer sur le sens que vous devez
donner à la réforme des retraites ne pas
toucher au pouvoir d'achat des retraités
nous espérons tous dans l'âme la
ministre cette volte-face sera
l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
renforcer tous ceux qui contribuent
à permettre le maintien des personnes
âgées à leur domicile
pouvez vous nous dire où en est le
gouvernement sur ces sujets pour vous
répondre madame la ministre du travail
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mais tu le sénateur bernard
bonne oui ces dernières heures je crois
qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'émotion de questions sur la question
des exonérations ou non de charges
patronales pour l'emploi à domicile des
personnes âgées pour celles qui ne sont
pas dépendantes je rappelle le principe
qu'il ya trois étages dead pour l'emploi
à domicile un premier qui concerne le
crédit d'impôt puisque tous les
employeurs à domicile le que c'est
environ 600000 personnes directement ou
indirectement par des associations et
des entreprises spécialisées
bénéficier du crédit d'impôt qui permet
de prendre en charge la moitié des coûts
salariaux et de cotisations il ya une
deuxième aide qui existent aussi pour
tous les âges et toutes les employeurs à
domicile qui sont une exonération
partielle des charges patronales et
ensuite il y à une troisième aide qui ne
concerne que les personnes dépendantes
ou les personnes de plus de 70 ans qui
est l'exonération complète des charges
patronales donc oui il y a eu une
hypothèse sur lequel nous avons
travaillé de garder les deux premiers
étages c'est à dire le crédit d'impôt
pour tous les la baisse de charges pour
tous mais de concentrer les baises
pardon la suppression des charges
patronales les charges patronales
entièrement sur les personnes qui en
avaient le plus besoin les plus faibles
et notamment les personnes dépendantes
compte tenu de la compréhension et du
manque de temps aussi dans un projet de
loi de finances qui va démarrer dans
quelques temps de très rapidement le
gouvernement a décidé de renoncer de
nous retirer cette mesure
ceci dit je pense que la question que
vous posez qui va plus loin et qui est
beaucoup plus importante c'est la
question de l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de dépendance et
l'accompagnement du grand âge nous
allons tous vieillir en meilleure santé
plus longtemps c'est bien mais il faut
accompagner accompagné d'andré domicile
ce sera l'objet de la loi sur le grand
âge et la dépendance que portera agnès
buzyn l'année prochaine mais
par l'état notre collègue sophie
joissains pour le groupe de l'union
centriste chers collègues vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame agnès buzyn
ministre des solidarités la santé et
concerne la grève dans les services
d'urgences grève qui a débuté il ya six
mois madame la ministre en tant que
médecin vous mesurer à quel point les
personnels soignants un engagement
profond dans l'exercice de leur métier
cet engagement s'apparente le plus
souvent de l'abnégation et nous le
saluons le saluons bien bas
aujourd'hui ils sont à bout
impossibilité de prendre leurs jours de
repos heures supplémentaires pas
toujours payés sous-effectif dépression
burn-out risque d'erreur médicale accrue
le triste accident survenu aux urgences
psychiatrique de niort le dimanche 15
septembre en raison de l'absence d'un
service de sécurité de jour en est une
dérive illustration la crise urgence
n'est certes pas nouvelle le nombre de
passages annuels a doublé en 20 ans et
triplé depuis 1988 mais si la situation
s'est aggravée d'année en année elle est
aujourd'hui arrivé à un point critique
manque de lits aux urgences et dans les
services appropriés effectifs
insuffisants revalorisation salariés
salariale inexistante le pacte de
refondation d urgence que vous avez
présenté il ya quinze jours ouvre certes
des pistes intéressantes
et force est de constater qu'ils ne
semblent pas répondre à l'ensemble des
besoins des personnels de santé la grève
se poursuit envisagez vous des mesures
complémentaires et nouvelles afin de
débloquer cette situation
pour vous répondre la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs man la sénatrice je
vous prie d'excuser l'absence de même
plus inquiète actuellement l'assemblée
nationale pourrait lois de bioéthique je
ne reviendrai pas sur les causes qui
sont à l'origine de la saturation des
services d'urgence le constat est connu
et partagé par tous ici non je vous
parlerai en effet de l'avenir et des
solutions que nous apportons avant l'été
le gouvernement avait sollicité le
député mme aigner et le professeur karl
i pour des propositions concrètes sur la
base de leur travail agnès buzyn a fait
la semaine dernière les présentations 7
de ce pacte de refondation en douze
mesures qui apportent les réponses
suivantes et qui ont été salués par bon
nombre de professionnels de santé pour
les patients nous souhaitons mettre en
place un service universel d'accès aux
soins pour tout ce qui relève des
besoins immédiats sans rendez-vous en
plus du médecin traitant qui reste le
premier palier il faut organiser aussi
un accès direct à l'hôpital pour les
personnes âgées sans passer par les
urgences et tout entreprendre pour
éviter au possible leur hospitalisation
chaque fois que cela est possible pour
les professionnels paramédicaux vous
l'avez souligné nous voulons que ces
métiers soit plus attractif nous avons
généralisé une prime pour tous aux
urgences étendue aux assistants
régulateurs et une prime de 80 euros
associé au protocole de coopération
nous allons développer un nouveau métier
ces infirmiers en pratique avancée avec
une rémunération augmenter enfin pour
tout l'hôpital il faut généraliser une
gestion de l'île informatisé et avec du
personnel il faut inviter les
établissements à contractualiser avec
tous les autres établissements killer
qui les environne pour accueillir les
patients après un passage aux urgences
enfin et c'est un combat que nous
voulons poursuivre c'est lutter contre
l'intérim qui pèse sur le budget des
hôpitaux les buts les moyens alloués
sont importants sont au rendez-vous 750
millions d'euros qui s'ajoutent au soin
qui s'ajoutent aux 70 millions d'euros
déjà engagés en juin nous écoutons les
professionnels puisque c'est sur le
terrain il y à partir d'eux puisque 80%
de cette enveloppe sera consacrée à des
moyens humains supplémentaires
je vous remercie
bell à brossard
ce sont effectivement des mesures qui
part est ambitieuse mais peut-être
faudra-t-il poursuivre voilà merci
merci la parole est à notre collègue
antoine karam pour le groupe de la
république en marche mon cher collègue
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il ya une
semaine à marseille vous avait dévoilé
les contours d'un nouveau plan anti
drogue chargé de réorganiser la lutte
contre le trafic de stupéfiants en
france outre la création d'un nouvel
office spéciale law face vous avez
annoncé la reconduction du plan d'action
interministériel lancé en mars dernier
pour renforcer la lutte contre le trafic
de stupéfiants en provenance de guyane
pour rappel celui ci représenteraient
selon l'observatoire français des
drogues et des toxicomanies près de 30%
du marché français évalué entre 25 et 30
tonnes dans le même temps guyane les
réseaux sociaux puis la presse ont
révélé que le 5 août dernier un colis
contenant huit kilos de cocaïne avaient
été retrouvés par hasard sur la coque du
bateau du cargo mn toucan navire
essentiellement consacrée au transport
d'éléments de la fusée ariane entre
kourou et l'hexagone je dis bien par
hasard puisque le colis aimanté à la
coque du cargo se serait détachée seul
attire ainsi l'attention du personnel du
port de pariacabo qui a donné l'alerté
aux autorités je ne suis pas de ceux qui
s'émerveillent de l'ingéniosité des
trafiquants je suis plutôt de ceux qui
s'inquiètent qu'une telle information
soit découverte plus d'un mois après les
faits je suis de ceux qui saluent risque
un cargo puisse partir d'un port aussi
surveiller que celui de kourou
principalement utilisé pour les besoins
du centre spatial guyanais avec à son
bord du matériel spatial et de la
cocaïne vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre je vous cite la france ne peut
pas être leur terrain de jeu de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique la guyane non plus
ne peut pas être un territoire où tout
est permis ou tous les moyens sont bons
pour faire transiter la drogue vers
l'europe alors monsieur le ministre je
vous le répète et je vous le demande
pouvez vous préciser comment ce nouveau
plan antidrogue permettra-t-il de mieux
lutter contre les trafics de marseille
jusqu'à cayenne en passant par paris
enfin quelles mesures spécifiques
entendez vous prendre pour sécuriser les
voies maritimes entre la guyane et
l'hexagone je vous remercie
on vous raconte la parole est là
monsieur laurent nunez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur comme vous le savez la lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants en
guyane en provenance de la guyane est
une priorité que nous avons avec
christophe castaner avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement depuis 2010 est nous avons
créé une antenne au christ à cayenne qui
est maintenant complètement opérationnel
nous avons renforcé les effectifs créer
des officiers de liaison qui sont
implantées au suriname et en guyana en
mars 2019 il y a quelques mois avec
plusieurs ministres nous avons lancé un
plan pour lutter contre les trafics dit
de mule c'est à dire des personnes qui
voyagent avec des produits stupéfiants
notamment de la cocaïne in corpore en
augmentant les contrôles que nous
effectuerons aux aéroports de cayenne à
orly mais aussi sur la frontière à saint
laurent du maroni le long du du suriname
et nous avons de nouveau augmenter les
effectifs pour lutter contre ce trafic
de cocaïne
et puis il y a le plan que vous dont
vous avez parlé le plan national qui a
été lancé à la demande du président de
la république et du premier ministre
pour lutter contre les stupéfiants qui
bien évidemment intègre les deux mesures
précédentes que je viens de citer les
actions engagées depuis 2010 est le plan
nul de 2019 et qui va renforcer la
coordination entre l'ensemble des
administrations concernées et donc
renforcer les contrôles qui vont être
menés par toutes les administrations sur
terre comme sur mer renforcer notre
réseau notre réseau d'officiers de
liaison dans les différents pays
d'amérique du sud et d'amérique centrale
et bien sûr renforcé les contrôles
portuaire sur les ports d'entrée en
france donc ce plan comporte bien des
mesures qui vont permettre de lutter
contre le phénomène de trafic de stups
en présence de guyane je veux simplement
rappeler que depuis 2016 nous avons
triplé le nombre de saisies de cocaïne
en guyane passant de plus de 300 kg à
plus de 900 kilos entre 2016 et 2018 ces
plans ils produisent d'excellents
résultats et je ne doute pas que le
nouveau plan national produira les mêmes
résultats
le mode opératoire que vous avez décrit
monsieur le sénateur il est totalement
inédit c'est un mode opératoire qui vise
à détourner les contrôles renforcés que
nous mettons en place et nous avons bien
évidemment sensibiliser la gendarmerie
maritime pour prévenir de nouvelles
tentatives de fraude de cette manière
mais compter sur la détermination du
gouvernement pour lutter contre le
trafic de stups en provenance de guyane
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue jean yves
roux pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des solidarités et de la santé
l'été est terminé et le bulletin de
santé les services d'urgence est très
inquiétant les faits sont là à brut dans
nos départements les plus ruraux entier
est ce sont des organes vitaux et
structurant des territoires qui lâchent
les uns après les autres dans les alpes
de haute provence mais la situation est
similaire aux quatre coins de la france
et des territoires d'outre-mer l'organe
vital des urgences de sisteron est
touché de plein fouet et du ennuis ont
été suspendus cet été et non pas rouvert
depuis trois passes et 2001 qu'elle
appelle l'organe vital des urgences de
digne-les-bains vient d'être touchée à
son tour l'hôpital qui assure 20
millions jans par an alors qu'un tel
service est viable et douze mille
patients s'apprête à perdre quatre
postes mêmes mots même constat pour
l'organe résidence de manosque mes chers
collègues vous connaissez tous la
chanson or les médicaments et pratique
réanimatoires mobilisés ne produisent
pas les effets escomptés
je pense au recours massif aux sapeurs
pompiers et à la mutualisation des samu
chacun sait ici sur ces bas que ce ne
sont pas des situations durable
humainement écologiquement et financier
romain alors oui des recrutements sont
prévus mais les candidats ne se
bousculent pas car comment les hôpitaux
peuvent rêver rita ise avec des
structures privées qui s'arrête la nuit
et sélectionner les pathologies comment
rivaliser quand les services de biologie
au plateau technique ne sont pas sur
place comment rivaliser avec des
salaires faramineux en intérim de plus
de 1200 euros par jour qui flatte les
comportements mercenaires madame la
ministre
des mesures structurelles ont été prises
mais comme toute mesure structurelle
cela prend du temps hors du temps nous
en avons pas parce qu'il s'agit de la
vie et de la santé de l'industrie mais
aussi de la survie de nos territoires
nous sommes tous des élus engagés au
quotidien pour notre développement local
le numérique les formations au
classement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
comment pourrions-nous en effet accepté
que tout notre travail soit balayée de
très forte de décès dans nos services
d'urgence madame irma question est une
proposition car chaque territoire
portant lui ces solutions car
organiserait voûté grenelle 2 urgence
dans tous les départements dans les
alpes et provence nous y sommes prêts
maintenant pour vous répondre la parole
et
sava secrétaire d'état madame la
ministre estime du boss merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs
dessinateur les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur j'entends votre question et
geoffrey par un amusant qui n'est
malheureusement pas là cet après midi
mais la ministre s'est attaquée dès son
arrivée au ministère à ce sujet à cette
préoccupation des urgences notamment en
proposant un texte de loi par le biais
de ma santé 2022 qui en fait ne
s'attaque pas à mettre à une réponse je
dirais aux symptômes et d'attraper
d'apporter des réponses sur le long
terme et ses réponses sur le long terme
fait part notamment de ce que je viens
de présenter avec la refonte des
urgences qui aujourd'hui comme je lé
dinh n'est plus de regarder en arrière
mais en effet de construire l'avenir de
notre nouveau système se trouvaient
ensemble ensemble avec les
professionnels ensemble avec les
collectivités ensemble avec les élus des
solutions de fonds durables et
innovantes
les urgences ne peuvent plus être la
porte d'entrée du système de santé tout
entier nous pouvons et nous devons
passer à l'action pour apporter aux
français une alternative concrète et
attractive au toute urgence nous devons
créer la ministre l'a rappelé le grand
service d'accès aux soins qui manque à
notre système de santé nous devons
changer les modes de financement aller
plus loin et plus vite oui sur la
reconnaissance et la valorisation de
toutes les compétences des soignants
mais aussi mieux protéger celles ceux
qui nous soignent au quotidien nous
devons ensuite enfin je dirais garantir
que trouver les lits d'aval ne soit plus
un casse tête et regardez les besoins en
face dans chaque territoire et il n'y a
aucune consigne au niveau national de
fermeture des lits au contraire nous
devrons en ouvrir là où les besoins sont
nécessaires et surtout en aval les
urgences nous avons décidé la ministre a
décidé de consacrer 750 millions d'euros
à ce plan de refondation des urgences
plus et 70 millions d'euros ajouté avant
l'été justement pour répondre aussi au
caractère d'urgence liées aux périodes
estivales ce sont près d'un milliard
d'euros qui sont mis sur cette période
là pour trouver ensemble la réponse à ce
problème de santé et avec ces temps ces
moyens là c'est tout le système de ma
santé 2022 que nous complétons et que
nous accélérons je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
cathy apourceau poly pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes pour deux minutes merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à la ministre du travail vous
avez annoncé renoncer à supprimer dès
l'an prochain un avantage accordé jusqu
alors à toutes les personnes âgées de
plus de 70 ans qui emploie une aide à
domicile ce n'est pas de l'amateurisme
de la part de votre gouvernement
mais le signe de votre des connexions
avec la réalité du quotidien de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens
vous espériez ainsi piqué 300 millions
d'euros dans les poches des retraités
mais après la baisse de leur pouvoir
d'achat
suite à la hausse de la csg et la
désindexation des pensions de retraite
la colère vous a contraint à renoncer
et c'est tant mieux c'était le coup de
trop à six mois des élections
municipales pour votre majorité ma
question est donc la suivante maintenant
que vous avez reculé sur les aides à
domicile
quand allez vous renoncer à votre
réforme scélérate des retraites par
points qui va en diminuer le montant
madame
monsieur le ministre jean paul delevoye
que nous retrouvons ici dans cette
maison monsieur le ministre à qui nous
souhaitons le meilleur mesdames
mais chez le président j'allais dire
presque chers collègues ravi de vous
retrouver d'autant plus madame apourceau
poly que le projet de société que nous
portons sous votre autorité monsieur le
président ainsi que celle de nombreux
sénateurs je pense à jean marie
vanlerenberghe et d'autre vous aviez
déjà anticipé notamment sur le système à
points
cette réforme voyez-vous nos concitoyens
ont un regard sur le système actuel sans
ambiguïté il le trouve injuste
illisible complexe difficilement pid est
pilotable et surtout pas adapté aux
mobilités professionnelles nouvelle et
la question de fond que nous nous sommes
posée par rapport quel est le principe
de base de la protection sociale du 21e
siècle
comment garantir que l'avenir des
retraites se basera uniquement sur des
solidarités professionnels nous offrons
en réalité quelles que soient vos
parcours quelles que soient vos statuts
quelles que soient vos professions la
solidité de la nation pour renforcer la
cohésion interrégionales rationnelle et
faire en sorte que les principes
universels soient claires à métier
identique retraite identique à
cotisation égale retraite égale
la police
monsieur le ministre nous sommes du même
département mais évidemment nous ne
portons pas le même projet de société
vous refusé d'entendre la voix des
milliers de personnes qui ont manifesté
samedi je vous rappelle que samedi il ya
eu de grandes manifestations vous refusé
d'entendre la voix de ceux qui étaient
dans la rue tout à l'heure et nous
étions avec mes collègues du groupe crc
eux aux côtés de ces milliers de
manifestants que vous ne voulez pas
entendre et qui remettent en cause votre
régime de retraite que évidemment vous
leur présentez une société moderne
monsieur doit accorder aux salariés le
repos et pour cela il faut qu'il soit en
bonne santé notre système de retraite
universel par répartition garantie cela
et pour permettre à toutes et à tous un
départ à la retraite dès 60 ans à
37,5 annuités nous proposons de
soumettre à contribution les 51
milliards d'euros de dividendes versés
aux actionnaires au second semestre 2010
9 merci merci
la parole est maintenant président
patrick nerfs pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ce premier ministre je vais y
aller franchement directement à quoi
joue le président de la république
que cherche-t-il en stigmatisant il ya
une semaine de manière frontale le droit
d'asile dans notre pays quel est ce
préjugé qui voudrait que les classes
populaires seraient obligatoirement anti
migrants d'ailleurs quelle est cette
nouvelle vision insidieuse que suggère
le président entre les catégories de
français vision d'une nouvelle division
finalement entre les français je vous
interroge sur tout cela parce que nous
ne comprenons pas où le président veut
nous emmener si ce n'est faire des
raccourcis contre lesquelles il a été
élu dans un front républicain en mai
2017 nous ne comprenons pas non plus
quel est le sens en termes de santé
publique de la restriction voulue par
l'exécutif sur l'aide médicale d'état
restrictions d'accès qui cède la plus
grande démagogie que j'ai parfois
malheureusement déjà entendus sur la
droite de notre hémicycle
enfin et de manière plus
circonstancielle
cette nouvelle offensive du président
sur les flux migratoires
signifie tels que la loi du 10 septembre
2018 dite loi asile immigration dont
l'encré à peine sèche était mal fait
monsieur le premier ministre comme nous
le dénoncions à l'époque nous vous
demandons des explications monsieur
premier ministre car il est de plus en
plus inquiétant que le président tienne
un double discours qui dénonce les
populismes et extrémisme au niveau
international tout en embrayant sur des
idées différentes en termes de discours
au plan national
parler le langage de son adversaire
c'est un jour prendre le risque de le
faire gagner alors oui monsieur le
premier ministre quel est ce jeu dans
lequel vous voulez nous entraîner
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président caennais la semaine dernière
j'avais avec quelques membres du
gouvernement et les parlementaires de la
majorité le plaisir d'écouter le
président de la république nous indiquer
un certain nombre d'éléments de
politiques publiques auxquelles il croit
et faire état devant la majorité d'un
certain nombre de convictions vous
n'étiez pas présent et c'est bien
naturel puisque vous ne soutenez pas
l'action du président de la république
et que vous ne votez pas la confiance du
gouvernement et il y à là strictement
rien à redire mais mais monsieur le
président le discours qu'a tenu le
président de la république les propos
qu'il a prononcée ne se réduisent pas à
la présentation que vous en faites et
peut-être parce que là
ce qu on vous en a dit était incomplet
il se trouve que j'étais présent vous
monsieur le président et que j'ai
entendu in extenso ce qu'a dit le
président de la république et que j'ai
entendu un discours d'une grande
précision d'une grande fermeté et d'une
grande ouverture
monsieur le président caennais j'ai dit
à l'occasion de la déclaration de
politique générale que le parlement
assemblée nationale et sénat aurait
l'occasion de discuter à la rentrée
septembre fin septembre début octobre de
la politique migratoire au sens le plus
large pour notre pays
depuis les politiques dead publique au
développement ou de coopération vers les
pays d'origine
jusqu aux conditions d'intégration des
étrangers qui venu en france ont
vocation à rester dans notre territoire
sans texte et sans mesure pourquoi parce
que très souvent lorsque nous évoquons
ce sujet nous le faisons à partir d'un
texte ou d'un ensemble de mesures et que
c'est parfaitement légitime mais
toujours un peu réducteur l'objectif du
gouvernement l'objectif annoncé est
évoquée par le président de république
c'est que la représentation nationale
puisse débattre dans toutes ses
dimensions des questions que posent les
migrations internationales européennes
nationales
de l'amont à l'aval
premier point deuxième fois parler de
l'immigration n'est pas un gros mot et
n'est pas un petit sujet nos concitoyens
en parle nos concitoyens vivent cette
question ont des avis à formuler ils
sont parfois divers souvent
contradictoires ils sont parfois
empreint d'angoise ou de colère ils sont
parfois empreint d'espoir et d'ouverture
mais monsieur le président imaginez que
ce débat n'est pas au centre des
préoccupations me semble méconnaître
assez largement la réalité de ce qui se
passe dans l'opinion publique on a
parfaitement le droit monsieur le
président de ne pas être d'accord vous
et moi mais j'ai le sentiment qu évoqué
de la façon la plus large possible ce
sujet au sein de la représentation
nationale n'est pas un contresens
troisième point puisque vous
m'interrogez sur la question de l'asile
et je ne veux pas faire le débat que
nous aurons longuement la semaine
prochaine monsieur le président mais
puisque vous m'interrogez sur le droit
d'asile le président de la république a
toujours indiqué il l'a fait pendant sa
campagne il a fait systématiquement
depuis et il l'a fait ce jour là mais
vous n'étiez pas présent il a toujours
indiqué qu'il était attaché au droit
d'asile qui est un droit qui n'est pas
un droit sacré car parler au sénat d'un
droit sacré aurait quelque chose de
provocateur qui est un droit
consubstantiel même pas seulement la
république à la france ce droit est
consubstantielle à ce que nous sommes et
il sera préservé le président la
république l'a dit je le dis et je crois
qu'ici personne n'est contre cette idée
mais regardons en face la réalité
monsieur le président caennais regardons
la tel cas les voyons le fait que les
demandes d'asile en europe diminue
nettement alors qu'en france et
seulement en france elle en augmente
très nettement voyons le fait qu'un très
grand nombre de ces demandes d'asile
sont issus de pays qui sont des pays que
nous pourrions assez facilement je crois
vous et moi reconnaître comme des pays
sûr ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de demandes d'asile qui
émanerait de ces pays mais ça veut dire
qu'il ya évidemment un problème quand la
demande est massive alors que ces pays
sont considérés comme sûrs et nous
devons regarder ces problèmes en face
monsieur le président ne pas nous nous
abriter derrière des postures tels que
nous dirions ça vous inquiète mais ne
vous inquiétez pas car il ya pas de
problème parlons-en discutons-en avec un
esprit ouvert et précis c'est exactement
le sens avec lequel nous avons dans
cette discussion du point de vue du
gouvernement pour voir dans tous les
domaines ce que nous pouvons faire
conformément aux principes qui nous
guide pour obtenir des résultats à la
hauteur des enjeux je vous remercie
monsieur le président caennais
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre ni angélisme de
l'autre pas rassurez vous mais pas d'
amalgame non plus et nous serons
toujours du côté de ceux qui pensent que
la solidarité internationale n'est pas
une charge mais un devoir pour un pays
comme la france et de qui pensent que la
fraternité n'est pas dans l'ordre vise
un public n quelque chose qu'il faut
passer par pertes et profits dans nos
principes mêmes républicains ce prêt
ministre vous m'avez répondu
essentiellement sur la méthode nous
serons là pour vous dire ce que nous
pensons le 2 octobre prochain au nom du
groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président
a parlé à notre collègue daniel chassa
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires au bénin
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise de
l'agriculture elles concernent le
secteur d'élevage qui connaît de grandes
difficultés avec un prix de vente des
bovins et ovins au niveau d'il ya 20 ans
n'ont augmenté par la loi galim première
question sera sur la sécheresse
l'agriculture devra poursuivre vivre
survivre diversifier ses productions
avec la mise en place de retenues
colinéaires pour stocker l'eau de pluie
afin de permettre la breuvage des
animaux et l'irrigation des cultures
monsieur le ministre comment pourrait en
faciliter la procédure du stockage de
l'eau beaucoup trop long beaucoup trop
complexe par rapport à d'autres états
européens
enfin quel bilan et qu'elle aide les
pouvoirs publics peuvent elles apporter
cette année aux éleveurs victimes de
sécheresse qui vont être obligés de
vendre des stocker une partie de leurs
animaux un cours effondré la deuxième
question concerne c'est a signé le 30
octobre partiellement appliquée avant la
ratification des parlements mais qui
aura des effets bénéfiques pour certains
secteurs mais ce ne sera pas du tout le
cas pour l'élevage notamment la viande
bovine puisque ce sont les règles de
l'om sait qui s'applique et
n'interdisent pas les fables are in
animals pour l'élevage ma question sont
les suivantes comment allez vous
appliquer l'article 44 de la loi et
galim qui prévoit l'interdiction de
proposer à la vente ou distribués à
titre gratuit des produits importés pour
lesquels il a été fait usage de produits
vétérinaires ou d'aliments pour animaux
interdit par la réglementation
européenne
les éleveurs inquiets ont besoin de vous
entendre de nouveau être rassuré sur ce
point enfin quelles compensations
seraient mises en place dans le secteur
de l'élevage pour permettre la vie la
viabilité des exploitations après le 7 à
jour merci mme celui pour vos réponses
sur ces deux questions que les éleveurs
attendent avec impatience pour la
pérennité du secteur
la parole est à monsieur le ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
monsieur marc fesneau monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chat simple
permettez moi avant toute chose de vous
prier d'excusés le ministre de
l'agriculture qui retenu à helsinki pour
un conseil européen des ministres de
l'agriculture sur un sujet important qui
n'est pas complètement délier de votre
question qui est la future pac votre
question porte sur la situation des
éleveurs et comporte deux volets le
premier sur le volet sécheresse qui a
une nouvelle fois touché la quasi
totalité des pays pour la deuxième année
consécutive
face à ce type de situation l'objectif
est de pouvoir mobiliser le maximum
d'herbe pour pouvoir la stocker nourrir
les animaux et éviter comme vous l'avez
dit la décapitalisation le midi de
l'agriculture ainsi immédiatement décidé
d'activer les dérogations prévues dans
ces cas pour les cas de force majeure et
c'est ainsi cet été 69 départements qui
ont été concernés par ailleurs pour
redonner de la trésorerie aux éleveurs
le ministre a demandé à la commission
européenne une augmentation du taux d'
avance des aides pac et l'ensemble des
mesures actives à blocs allemand en cas
de crise ont été mobilisés pour redonner
de la trésorerie aux agriculteurs
exonération de la taxe foncière sur les
propriétés non bâties report ou
allègement des cotisations versées à la
mutualité sociale agricole vous
permettra en outre de saluer
l'extraordinaire solidarité nouvelle
fois qui s'est exprimé dans le monde
agricole entre régions et qui a fait
qu'avec les organisations
professionnelles avec les syndicats avec
les d'agriculture ils ont pu organiser
entre eux aussi un système de solidarité
entre les agriculteurs ça c'est la
situation de l'urgence mais ces
événements climatiques posent également
comme vous l'avez dit la question de la
gestion de l'eau il faut continuer à
adapter nos pratiques pour réduire nos
consommations et surtout rendre nos
exploitations plus résiliente et pour ce
faire il faut que les agriculteurs est
un accès sécurisé et facilité à l'eau et
la france a accumulé reconnaissons le un
grand retard depuis des années sur ce
sujet nous avons récemment débloqué la
possibilité de construire des retenues
collective dans le cadre de projets de
territoire les pressions pour mission
désormais d'accompagner les projets des
agriculteurs dans leurs réalisations et
avec l exigence de le faire dans des
temps qui soit acceptable concernant
l'application de l'article 44 de la loi
galland vous avez été nombreux à nous
interpeller
le ceta ne modifie aucunement les règles
sanitaires applicables à l'entrée sur le
marché européen la réglementation
européenne interdit l'importation de
viande bovine issus d'animaux nourris
avec des farines animales de ruminants
et cette interdiction s'applique à tous
les produits importés du fait du risque
de transmission le sb et vous aurez ici
un débat sur le ceta qui permettra aussi
d'apporter un certain nombre de réponses
sur ces questionnements je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à m collègue daniel euros
pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole
le seul président monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question portera sur les zones de non
traitement comme le dit notre président
gérard larcher les maires sont apportés
d'engueulades alors pour peu qu'il soit
agriculteur c'est la double peine les
agriculteurs sont les noms et nouveaux
boucs émissaires un suicide tous les
deux jours ce n'est plus tolérable
la profession n'a pas attendu pour
travailler à l'élaboration de chartes
d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires à proximité des
habitations ou à s'organiser dans une
démarche de responsabilité
environnementale
les agriculteurs connaissent les
produits qu'ils utilisent ils ne vont
pas traiter les jours où les enfants
sont présents dans les écoles où le
dimanche à midi lorsque les familles des
jeunes sur la terrasse ce sont des
règles de bon sens la mise en place de
zones de non traitement doit nous
interpeller sur le principe même un
produit dangereux à 3 m le sera tout
autant à 10 ou à 150 est ce la distance
ou la dangerosité du produit la source
du problème la réduction d'utilisation à
la sortie des pesticides sont des enjeux
environnementaux économiques et sociaux
importants pour l'avenir mais qui
autorise la mise sur le marché
ce ne sont pas les agriculteurs que l'on
propose enfin des produits de
substitution avec une innocuité verrait
et une harmonisation européenne
les nst concerne à la fois l'agriculture
conventionnelle et biologique
je constate certaines incohérences
comment atteindre les objectifs de
surface à l'école d'agriculture
biologique si on supprime la possibilité
d'utiliser les produits homologués bio
tels que le cuivre par exemple monsieur
le ministre de l'agriculture l'a
justement indiqué des mnt à plus de 100
mètres c'est notre autonomie alimentaire
qui seraient mises à mal avec plus de 20
% de surfaces agricoles amputés et
l'obligation de se fournir sur le marché
mondial avec des garanties sanitaires et
environnementales moindre vous avez
lancé une consultation gageons que le
dialogue et la concertation dans nos
territoires l'emporteront monsieur le
premier ministre nous attendons votre
réponse merci
[Applaudissements]
dans vos réponses la parole est à madame
la secrétaire d'état après on a mis la
transition écologique et solidaire
madame emmanuelle wargon madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur daniel laurent pour
répondre à votre question au nom du
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire j'aimerais d'abord dire tout
mon soutien aux agriculteurs qui vivent
en ce moment des moments difficiles en
matière d'aghribs shing vous avez
rappelé les suicides des agriculteurs
nous devons soutenir la profession
agricole c'est le message du ministère
de la transition écologique comme le
message du ministère de l'agriculture
portait à la fois par didier guillaume
et par mon ministère est partout le
gouvernement la question qui nous est
posée est globalement la question de la
transformation avec les agriculteurs du
modèle agricole et nous l'avons engagé
moins de pesticides c'est le plan
ecophyto de à horizon 2025 moins 50% la
sortie progressive du glyphosate filière
par filière qui va nous permettre de
répondre à cette exigence de nos
concitoyens avec les agriculteurs
l'augmentation de la surface agricole en
bio nous avons un objectif à 15 % de
cette surface agricole et nous sommes en
bonne voie avec une progression très
forte des dernières années et le
règlement progressif des aides par la sp
ce travail nous le menons avec les
agriculteurs pour défendre toutes les
agricultures en france l'agriculture bio
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
les agriculture raisonnée et
l'agriculture conventionnelle
la question des aides entre des zones de
non traitement est une question de
protection des populations
la décision que nous avons prise avec le
texte mis à la consultation est fondée
sur la vie de l'ansès avis scientifiques
d'une agence qui posent entre 3 et 10 m
les zones de non traitement on est bien
loin des coudes comme des maires qui
sont à 150 mètres et qui voudraient rayé
du jour au lendemain 20 % de la surface
agricole utile néanmoins nous avons
besoin de ces zones de non traitement
nous en avons besoin pour prendre une
mesure générale qui permettra
d'accompagner les mesures qui sont déjà
dans les autorisations de mise sur le
marché et qui sont d'ailleurs parfois
plus élevé en fonction de la nature du
produit ou de l'ase la consultation nous
permettra d'avancer ce sujet merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
viril jours pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre auprès
de la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales chargé des
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre la loi matam
portant création de la métropole aix
marseille provence a prévu de doter ce
nouvel établissement public de
coopération intercommunale de plusieurs
compétences dites de proximité le
transfert de la compétence voirie
communale devait initialement être mise
en oeuvre avant le 1er janvier 2018 la
loi relative au statut de paris à
l'aménagement métropolitain du 28
février 2017 a finalement repoussé cette
échéance au 1er janvier prochain depuis
ce report le débat sur l'avenir de la
métropole
amp s'est poursuivi monsieur le premier
ministre a demandé l'an passé au préfet
de région de conduire une mission de
concertation sur les mutations possibles
de l'actuelle le pci dans cette
perspective un dialogue a été établi
avec les élus locaux et un rapport a été
remis au gouvernement ces échanges et
les travaux conduits par monsieur le
préfet font apparaître une préoccupation
commune de voir la métropole se
concentrer sur les projets les plus
structurants de son territoire tout en
renvoyant l'exercice de certaines
compétences de proximité notamment la
voirie vers les communes au plus près du
terrain un transfert au 1er janvier 2020
des compétences création aménagement et
entretien de voirie et création
aménagement et entretien des espaces
publics dédiés à tous modes de
déplacements urbains ainsi qu'à leurs
ouvrages accessoires n'apparaît plus
opportun au moment où une réflexion
nouvelle est engagé sur la répartition
des rôles entre communes et métropole
dans les bouches du rhône aussi monsieur
le ministre dans la tente des
propositions de l'exécutif sur le
devenir de la métropole amp le
gouvernement serait-il favorable à une
annulation ou un nouveau report du
transfert de ses compétences
vont répondre la parole est ministre
chargé des collectivités territoriales
sébastien lecornu que j'avais la parole
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs entament la sénatrice si nous
sommes pragmatiques qui vous avez
rappelé les dispositions de lois map tam
qui font qu effectivement un certain
nombre de deux d'éléments continue dans
le calendrier tel que le législateur
n'avait imaginé puis on est pragmatique
est-ce que ce transfert de compétence
voirie peut se faire dans de bonnes
conditions au 1er janvier 2020 si on
écoute l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire la réponse est non donc
faut-il donner plus de temps comme vous
le demander cet après midi d'autres
parlementaires d'ailleurs quelles que
soient les sensibilités politiques ont
saisi gouvernement sur le sujet le
sénateur amiel encore fait ce matin donc
oui la loi engagement et proximité qui
arrivera devant vous au début du mois
d'octobre doit permettre par voie
d'amendement de permettre son report il
faut converger en discutant avec les
élus métropolitains sur une durée qui
soit suffisamment significative pour que
la fois prochaine soit la bonne ce qui
permettra d'avancer par ailleurs sur
l'ensemble des autres questions
institutionnelles que koné marseille
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue line renaud garabédian pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole ma chère collègue aussi le seul
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre daumas
cook le plus vieux voyagistes au monde
vient de déposer son bilan les 106 100
mille voyageurs en attente de
rapatriement dont dix mille français
mais c'est aussi et surtout tout un
ensemble de prestataires qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation
périlleuse hôteliers restaurateurs
autocaristes organisateurs de spectacles
de croisière en métropole aux antilles
en corse ce ne sont pas moins de 2000
locations touristiques
plusieurs centaines d'hôtels près de 200
croisière 500 clubs de vacances et
campings monsieur le ministre à court
terme la promesse de thomascook et
d'indemniser l'ensemble de ses clients
mais qu'en est il de ces prestataires
auquel thomascook n'aura rien verser et
qui sont dans l'incapacité de revendre
leur prestation dans un délai très court
je vous rappelle que les pme du secteur
du tourisme sont déjà dans une situation
économique tendue après les mois de
violences en marge des manifestations du
gilet jaune qui ont provoqué des pertes
de chiffres d'affaires importantes non
d'années de mise à bhl à moyen terme
quel va être l'avenir de près de 400
agences de masse cook en france filiales
en propre ou franchisés enfin à long
terme monsieur le ministre n'assistons
nous pas par la faillite de thomasz
crook un phénomène beaucoup plus large
d'effondrement du modèle économique
les agences de voyages physiques aux
produits d'un modèle dématérialisée où
seuls les géants comme expedia booking
web google pourront subsister merci
monsieur le ministre pour vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état en
charge des transports monsieur jean
baptiste chevarie kiprop pour la
première fois la parole de notre
hémicycle qu'il soit le bienvenu merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'autre question porte sur la
situation de thomascook placé en
situation de liquidation judiciaire hier
et vous l'avez dit qu'il pose la
question de la fragilité de certains
opérateurs du secteur touristique face à
une concurrence intense et à la montée
des plateformes numériques s'agissant
précisément de la situation des dix
mille français qui se trouve avoir
acheté des billets et pour lesquels les
billets sont annulés il ya en fait trois
cas il ya ceux qui ne sont pas encore
partis en voyage et pour lesquels
thomascook rembourse intégralement le
prix du voyage il ya ceux qui sont
partis mais pour lesquels les transports
aériens sont indépendants de la
compagnie thomascook et qu'ils peuvent
continuer leur trajet sans difficulté et
il ya ceux pour lesquels effectivement
la situation est plus complexe à ceux
dans ce cadre-là thomascook a mis en
place un numéro d'accès et les français
qui se trouvent dans cette situation
bénéficie d'un rapatriement pris en
charge
partout matt cooke sûr je vais donc vous
rassurer sur la situation des français
qui connaissent cette situation et vous
dire que les français sont bien protégés
dans le secteur du tourisme non
seulement par le mécanisme français dit
a pesté mais aussi par le système de
garantie européen et s'agissant
saisissant évidemment des prestataires
que vous avez cités les services de
bercy seront en lien avec eux pour
prendre les mesures de soutien adapté
enfin sur la dimension de l'emploi ce
sont 7 181 français 780 emplois français
qui sont actuellement en question qui
sont actuellement touchés par ces par
cette mesure le gouvernement est en lien
avec la direction de thomas cook france
et prendra les mesures de soutien adapté
là aussi vous pouvez compter sur notre
vigilance et notre action je vous
remercie
merci madame
hairabedian d'avril
merci monsieur 2010 de vos clés ces
exercices mans bien évidemment nous
serons très attentifs à l'évolution de
la situation pour les pme
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
corinne féret pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre après la hausse de la
csg après la décision de ne plus indexer
les retraites sur le coût de la vie
avant une réforme des retraites qui
réduira inévitablement le niveau des
pensions et creusera les inégalités
le gouvernement comptait s'attaquer de
nouveau aux personnes âgées en ciblant
cette fois l'exonération de charges
sociales dont bénéficient les plus de 70
ans empoignant une aide à domicile
encore un mauvais coup porté à leur
pouvoir d'achat or nous venons
d'apprendre que le gouvernement renoncé
à cette mesure qui devait pénaliser près
de 800 mille bénéficiaires face à l'émoi
suscité par une décision injuste prise
sans concertation constatant une fois de
plus que la méthode n'est pas la bonne
monsieur le premier ministre l'a reconnu
lui-même à l'assemblée nationale cet
après midi et a été contraint de reculer
à deux jours de la présentation du
budget veille du conseil des ministres
vous êtes dans l'improvisation la plus
totale
pour autant d'autres mesures d'économie
annoncées dans le prochain budget 2020
sont particulièrement inquiétantes
revalorisation des allocations
familiales des pensions de retraite des
apl inférieure à l'inflation à cela
s'ajoute la suppression des services
publics de proximité et je pense
particulièrement trésorerie dans nos
territoires
je n'oublie pas non plus la réforme de
l'assurance chômage aux conséquences
désastreuses pour les plus précaires un
chômeur sio2 vers un son allocation
baissé aussi madame la ministre question
est simple pouvez vous vous engagez sur
ces mesure profondément injuste à revoir
votre copie en privilégiant cette fois
la concertation et le dialogue social
[Applaudissements]
en afrique où j'avais la parole monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice corinne
féret d'abord je crois que nous l'avons
évoqué le gouvernement a renoncé à
l'hypothèse
de suppression de l'exonération des
cotisations patronales et salariales
pour les employeurs à domicile
ça veut dire qu'on revient à la
situation actuelle pour que soit clair
pour tous ça veut dire que une personne
qui emploie à domicile personnes qu'il
aide pour le ménage ou pour les gardes
d'enfants ou pour les travaux de travaux
à domicile aujourd'hui bénéficier d'une
aide importante puisque il ya à la fois
un crédit d'impôt une baisse de charge
et cette baisse de charge supplémentaire
pour les personnes en situation de
dépendance ou en situation ou un jeu de
plus de 70 ans qu'est ce que ça
représente pour quelqu'un qui embauchent
cinq heures par semaine 20 heures par
mois à 10 euros net de l'heure ce qui
est la moyenne constatée en dehors de la
région parisienne une personne à
domicile le coût net le salaire qui est
versé à la personne qui a embauché et 2
200 euros le coût du travail complet
avec les charges et de 367 euros le coup
après les crédits d'impôt et après les
baisses de charges il est de 167 euros
donc on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
politique de à la fois de maintien d'un
point à domicile au maximum des
personnes âgées mais aussi de soutien
alors à domicile est très active les
choix qu'il faut je prends cet exemple
pour dire qu'il faudra garder les choses
comme elles sont et c'est pareil pour
l'assurance chômage pour l'assurance
chômage aucun demandeur d'emploi doit
avoir son capital de droit diminué
simplement ce qu'ils gagnaient plus
provisoirement en travaillant non pardon
au chômage qu'en travaillant auront une
indemnité chômage qui n'est jamais
supérieurs à leur travail par contre
elle sera plus longue de même il faudra
avoir travaillé six mois dans les 24
mois pour bénéficier de l'assurance
chômage mais du coup on ne bénéficiera
au moins six mois alors qu'avant c'était
qu'à toi je crois que c'est une réforme
équilibrée doté d'un investissement très
fort dans l'accompagnement et en
regardant les faits je pense que nous
pourrons nous rapprocher
si la parole
24 secondes sans votre réponse madame la
ministre et deux précisions sur
l'assurance chômage c'est une étude de
l'unedic qui le dit plus de 40% des
indemnisés aujourd'hui verront leur
montant d'allocation diminué c'est une
réalité cet objectif enfin si on les
réformes moi aussi nous tous mais nous
particulièrement nous entendons les
français nous entendons la colère qui
monte et cela ne veut pas dire que
concertée comme vous prétendez le faire
est une écoute cela ne veut pas dire non
plus que lorsqu'on concertent et qu'on
écoute on a déjà des réponses avant même
d'engager tout débat mais si la parole
maintenant notre collègue sonia de la
provôté pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
ils avaient la part
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre shah collègues ma question
porte sur la circulaire dite zéro
artificialisation net parue dans l'été
invitons les préfets à la fermeté
vis-à-vis des documents d'urbanisme tant
sur le fond que sur la forme il ne
souffle pas vraiment un esprit de
décentralisation dans ce texte pourtant
alors que le dialogue entre les élus des
territoires et le gouvernement s'étaient
réchauffées cette circulaire signée par
quatre ministres ne refroidissent
sérieusement si la sobriété la
consommation foncière dont la lutte
contre l'artificialisation est un
objectif réel est louable et j'ose le
dire partager en revanche la méthode
proposée jette l'opprobre sur les élus
locaux des rendant suspect d'une
inconscience coupable que les préfets
l'état accompagne la rédaction des
documents d'urbanisme c'est légitime et
même souhaitable ces échanges dans le
respect sont indispensables mais là si
le document approuvé va à l'encontre de
l'objectif affiché il est demandé au
préfet je cite de mobiliser tout
l'éventail de levier réglementaire qui
va de l'avis défavorable jusqu'à la
suspension du caractère exécutoire du
document donc les élus concernés
dialogue avec l'état décide d'ensemble
en conscience d'un document d'urbanisme
qu'ils votent l'étape tout bloquer a
posteriori et sur quels critères
que pèse donc le vote des élus d'un scot
aux yeux de l'état ou et l'autonomie des
collectivités
vous le savez les territoires qui vont
en pâtir sont seuls même qui voit les
services partir la poste et écoles
fermées leurs populations vieillir pour
quelques territoires jugés
déraisonnables
on décide de les ai tous les autres
monsieur le ministre des mots ont un
sens en ces temps de dialogue affichée
attendre des préfets qu'ils provoquent
je cite une prise de conscience et une
modification des comportements
c'est leur prêter bien plus qu'un rôle
règlementaire vous en conviendrez essais
vexatoires monsieur le ministre et
territoires sont inquiets comment
comptez-vous les rassurer et garantira
une petite commune rurale qu'elle a un
avenir dans la république
[Applaudissements]
pour répandre la parole et ministre en
charge de la ville et du logement
jeu de normandie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice la circulaire en question
concerne l'artificialisation des sols
c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui est d'une
importance très très forte et partagée
par nous toutes et tous je sais
notamment tous les travaux faits par
plusieurs d'entre vous sur ce sujet
parce que cette artificialisation des
sols ça doit d'abord répondre à une
volonté politique au niveau national et
au niveau local et porter profondément
par les élus locaux c'est par exemple
cette volonté politique qui nous a
conduits à faire un choix un véritable
choix en disant que pour certaines
villes fameuse ville moyenne je déteste
ce terme mais c'est comme ça qu'elles
sont appelées nous avons pris la
décision de réorienter l'investissement
locatif je parle bien de
l'investissement locatif vers la
réhabilitation des centres villes parce
que ni vous ni nous ne pouvons accepter
de voir ces centres villes qui périclite
alors que c'est centre-ville son
identité notre pays la beauté de notre
territoire et tout ça au profit d'autres
zones qu'ils pouvaient se mettre en
oeuvre et puis cette volonté politique
madame la sénatrice vous le savez très
bien elle nous a conduit également plus
tôt elle nous oblige également à
procéder avec deux orientations
principales la première c'est qu'il n'y
a aucune solution qui peut se définir de
manière unique et s'appliquer partout
sur le territoire on a eu des débats ici
sur les dents creuses sur les centres
villes que je viens d'évoquer sur la
densification ici ou là sur
l'aménagement du territoire par les
maisons individuelles sur d'autres
territoires et donc cette approche
territoriale is et je peux vous en êtes
sûr et nous serons 40 de ceux de celui
ci et puis le deuxième objectif je crois
madame la sénatrice il ya quelques
années vous aviez rédigé un document qui
s'appelait quand le paysage fabrique la
ville moi j'irais même plus loin je
pense que le l'aménagement fabrique la
société et à ce titre l'aménagement est
un acte démocratique et à ce titre
puisque c'est un acte démocratique c'est
un acte qui ne peut être prise que par
les élus locaux et donc les préfets
lorsqu'on leur demande de lait de cette
circulaire on leur demande d'avoir un
rôle d'accompagnement des élus locaux
avec cette territorialisation et avec
cet accompagnement c'est ça notre
objectif et c'est ça que nous mettrons
en oeuvre soyez en assuré
photos et vous avez vous pouvez prendre
le micro
monsieur le ministre le dit justement
les territoires vous le savez sont
différents leurs besoins aussi à aucun
moment vous n'évoquez de la souplesse de
la nuance dans la part de la part des
préfets dans la circulaire cela ferait
pourtant assurément une bien meilleure
circulaire
nous avons fini merci monsieur le
premier guide a pesé messieurs les
ministres les prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
la semaine prochaine à une date que sera
déterminé ce soir par la conférence des
présidents
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 17h45 pour poursuivre le
projet de loi relatifs à l'aller contre
le gaspillage et l'économie circulaire
la séance est suspendue
c'est donc le recul du gouvernement sur
la suppression de l'aide fiscale pour
les personnes âgées qui emploie d'une
aide à domicile qui a ouvert la séance
des questions au gouvernement
alors le sénateur lr bernard bonne a
déploré que le gouvernement considère
les retraités comme étant des variables
d'ajustement budgétaire alors muriel
pénicaud la ministre du travail a dû
répondu par donc il y avait bien une
hypothèse sur laquelle le gouvernement
avait travaillé mais que compte tenu du
manque de temps le gouvernement y avait
renoncé autre sujet l'immigration alors
l'immigration donc qui est un sujet
rappelez-vous sur lequel avait parlé
emmanuel macron il y a quelques jours il
avait dit que les bourgeois ne croisait
pas l'immigration que c'était les
territoires les plus pauvres qui en
était le réceptacle alors patrick kanner
le président du groupe socialiste a dit
à quoi joue le président lors de ces
questions au gouvernement edouard
philippe le premier ministre lui a dit
qu il s'agissait là d'un discours d'une
grande fermeté d'une grande précision
d'une grande ouverture qu'avait tenus le
président et que parler d'immigration
n'était pas un gros mot n'était pas un
petit sujet et que le droit d'asile
allaient être préservé enfin à noter le
retour d'un ancien sénateur dans
l'hémicycle le l'actuel haut commissaire
à la réforme des retraites jean paul
delevoye qui a rejoint le gouvernement
récemment
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications et vous en avez parlé au
début de vos explications le coup de
rabot annulé gouvernement tout de suite
rejoindre alexandre poussin sur ce sujet
à votre micro est bien le patron des
sénateurs les républicains bruno
retailleau et oui bruno retailleau ce
renoncement du gouvernement finalement
sur ce coup de rabot fiscal qui
concernait les seniors et l'emploi des
personnes à domicile qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé de cette séquence abbas et un
couac évidemment mais c'est un couac qui
est très très inquiétant parce que le
gouvernement semble s'acharner sur nos
aînés sur les personnes âgées rappelez
vous on a eu d'abord 25% d'augmentation
de la csg ensuite on a eu la
désindexation des retraites est
désormais on s'attaque notamment à
l'emploi à domicile c'est grave parce
que on a un immense défi qu'elle
vieillissement on a un immense défi
qu'est le maintien à domicile et le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
chez elles coûtent beaucoup moins cher
que dans des structures collectives dans
les ehpad ou ou même parfois dans les
hôpitaux quand ça va mal donc non je
crois que là vraiment ce couac il veut
dire quelque chose et j'espère que sur
la réforme des retraites on va pas
s'attaquer au pouvoir d'achat des
retraités sur la méthode sur cette
décision verticale du ministère du
travail sans concertation est ce que
c'est de l'amateurisme selon vous abba
en tout cas on nous avait promis un acte
2 qui devait tout changer où on devait
avoir de la concertation tutti et on se
rend compte qu'on a des méthodes qui
sont prises de façon masquée de façon
cachée heureusement que celle ci a été
débusqué parce que sinon on y avaient
droit alors bernard born votre collègue
sénateur les républicains ont payé un
mot très fort les personnes âgées
seraient les boucs émissaires du
gouvernement est ce que c'est vrai on
peut le penser c'est le troisième
indistinct après la désindexation des
retraites notamment et puis avec la csg
je trouve que c'est inquiétant pour ce
qui est à venir sur les retraites je
pense que la réforme des retraites
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'affiche
pas le maintien dépôt du pouvoir d'achat
et je crois que ce qu'on doit demander
avant toute chose à une vraie réforme
des retraites c'est de dire nous
retraités d'aujourd'hui dès demain on va
vous garantir va pouvoir d'achat c'est
ce que j'attends du gouvernement pour
l'instant c'est flou et quand c'est flou
c'est avec
une question sur l'immigration puisque
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
été interpellé par votre collègue
président du groupe socialiste patrick
kanner notamment sur le discours qui
s'est durcie d'emmanuel macron sur la
politique migratoire est ce que ce
discours un peu durci le il vous
satisfait on sait jamais avec mails
macron si on a affaire à quelque chose
de sincère ou un coup de com et ce qui
est incroyable c'est que l'on fait
actuellement la promulgation le premier
anniversaire de la loi qu'a voulu
monsieur macron sur l'asile et
l'immigration en fait il a commenté ces
échecs puisque cette loi qui tout juste
promulguée il ya un an elle fonctionne
pas il a même été obligé de reconnaître
devant ce qu'on appelle la conférence
des ambassadeurs tous les autres
présidents de républiques fait venir de
tous les pays du monde nos propres
ambassadeurs les ambassadeurs de france
dans ce pays et il leur a dit voilà il
ya quelque chose qui marche pas la
france est devenue le premier pays
d'europe d'eurobonds pour les déboutés
du droit d'asile ça fonctionne pas sauf
que c'est l'échec que nous avions prédit
de sa loi asile immigration très bien
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau pour
votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction vous retrouve tout à l'heure
pour d'autres réactions dans la salle
des conférences on va continuer à
débriefer cette séance en plateau avec
mon invité ronan dantec bonjour vous
êtes un sénateur rdse de la loire
atlantique le temps fort de cette séance
était effectivement cette question qui a
ouvert la séance avec ce coup de rabot
annulé le gouvernement qui renonce donc
à supprimer cette aide à corner accordé
aux seniors destiné à l'emploi à
domicile
certains dans les rangs de la république
en marge excepté moralement contestable
politiquement inflammables c'est un
ballon d'essai qui habite imploser oui
mais je crois quand on voit bien qu'on a
un gouvernement qui est d'abord fondé
sur une orthodoxie budgétaire
qui effectivement après les gilet jaune
il ya eu un certain nombre de mesures
annoncées qui sont plutôt keynésienne au
sens de redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
classes populaires mais que ça n'est pas
assumée par ce gouvernement qui cherche
derrière des économies les cherchent des
parrains manière particulièrement
maladroite sur le fond comme sur la
forme donc un code de plus mais il faut
bien voir que derrière parce qu'on le
voit aussi avec la baisse du budget du
ministère de l'environnement 1500 postes
supprimés les prochaines c'est tout à
fait colossal je les connais
gouvernement reste dans une orthodoxie
financière qui n'a jamais marché et que
donc c'est là dessus qu'ils
effectivement il faut
marquer notre désaccord en disant que ça
n'est pas comme ça que la société
française a mieux supporté c'est une
erreur vous le déplorez de la part du
gouvernement les seniors sont ils les
boucs émissaires disait alexandre poussa
de ce gouvernement voit avec cela on va
aussi avec la réforme des retraites qui
qui s'annonce et qui met déjà du monde
dans la rue moi je crois que ceux qui
sont le plus en difficulté aujourd'hui
avec ce gouvernement c'est quand même
les gens qui ont de petits salaires qui
ont des situations précaires je crois on
l'a pas assez dit que la réforme
sur l'indemnité chômage qui avait
provoqué ni compris la la la la colère
de laurent berger pourtant toujours
à dialoguer va remettre dans la
précarité beaucoup de monde et qu'on a
au contraire besoin d'une société qui
protège toujours davantage les les plus
fragiles je crois que le politique il
est là d'abord pour protéger éclat
effectivement un certain nombre de
mesures qui s'empilent ne donne pas ce
message là autres temps forts tout à
l'heure on n'en doutait que lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
il ya eu la question posée par patrick
kanner autour de l'immigration avant ce
débat que l'on attend la semaine
prochaine au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale écouter tout de suite et bien
la réponse d'edouard philippe le premier
ministre j'ai dit à l'occasion de la
déclaration de politique générale que le
parlement assemblée nationale et sénat
aurait l'occasion de discuter à la
rentrée septembre fin septembre début
octobre de la politique migratoire au
sens le plus large pour notre pays
depuis les politiques dead publique au
développement ou de coopération vers les
pays d'origine
jusqu aux conditions d'intégration des
étrangers qui venu en france ont
vocation à rester dans notre territoire
ronan dantec est ce que vous pensez que
le gouvernement a raison d'aller sur ce
terrain
l'immigration ce n'est pas un gros mot
et du tout à la raideur philippe nom et
l'intégration non plus le problème c'est
qu'on n'a pas le sentiment et ça fait
écho à votre question précédente que
derrière le gouvernement va débloquer
beaucoup plus de moyens en termes
sociaux pour faciliter l'intégration
j'ai pas senti chez edouard philippe
cette logique là je crois qu'on agite
encore on n'avait pas passé la totalité
de sa réponse mais ce sentiment que la
france finalement ne peut pas faire face
à quelques milles et demandeurs d'asile
c'est assez absurde au contraire je
crois qu'il faudrait par exemple qu'on
soit extrêmement critique sur la
position qu'on a prise à à la frontière
entre la france et l'italie qui a nourri
le sentiment en italie que les italiens
était seul face à ce qu'ils
connaissaient en méditerranée et qui a
nourri salvini et qui a nourri salvini
et ça c'était la politique de colomb moi
je crois aujourd'hui que ce qui est le
plus déstabilisant avec un une petite
part de l'immigration c'est les gens qui
sont dans la rue c'est ça passe le
message que la société française ne peut
plus protéger et qu'au contraire la
priorité c'est qu'il n'y ait plus
personne dans la rue c'est comme ça
effectivement qu'on sécurise qu'on
rassure la société française
certainement pas en créant des boucs
émissaires on recréant des débats alors
que l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est très
très peu en termes démographiques et là
je ne comprends pas effectivement que le
président de la république est rouvert
ce débat en ces termes et leurs
électeurs c'est victor à laissac est ce
que ça veut dire qu'est ce que ça veut
dire enfermés le corner est bien sur les
terrains de la droite voire de l'extrême
droite est d'aller sur c est sur ces
sujets là bas je je je le crains peut
évidemment mais je crois qu'à un moment
il faut que nous à gauche on soit aussi
capable de dire finalement notre vraie
question ce qui rend anxiogène
aujourd'hui la société c'est des gens à
la rue c'est le fait que cette société
riche donne le sentiment que si on est
en difficulté parce qu'on est fragile
qu'on soit immigré conçoit travailleurs
précaires qu'on soit en mauvaise santé
on ne sera pas aidé et c'est là dessus
je crois que la gauche aujourd'hui d'en
repartir à l'offensive en disant notre
rôle sécuriser la société donc si le
gouvernement sort de ce débat qui avait
été annoncé par un an philippe en disant
nous allons faire plus pour mieux
accueillir ceux qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile donc qu'ils ont des droits en
france alors on ira dans le bon sens je
reste effectivement pour l'instant
plutôt inquiet si on les réponses qui
seront apportées à nantes avec vous
rester avec moi mais on va tout de suite
rejoindre alexandre poussa dans la salle
des conférences du sénat alexandre vous
êtes avec le sénateur socialiste jean
louis tourenne quelle est sa réaction à
ce que dit ronan dantec il dit le rôle
de la gauche est de dire notre rôle
c'est de sécuriser société oui jean
louis touraine est ce que le rôle de la
gauche dans ce début de mouvement social
contre la réforme des retraites c'est de
sécuriser la société
ça a toujours été le rôle de la gauche
de sécuriser la société de faire en
sorte que nous puissions vivre ensemble
de la meilleure façon possible ce qui
suppose qu'il y ait davantage de justice
sociale qu'il y ait davantage de
formation que chacun puisse s'intégrer
dans les meilleures conditions y compris
ceux qui viennent chez nous et qui
doivent pouvoir aussi bénéficier des
moyens de leur intégration à l'intérieur
de notre société dans la réforme des
retraites prévue par le gouvernement
comment la gauche peut finalement
apporté au débat et permettre que le
gouvernement revoie sa copie
je crois déjà qu'il ya des
manifestations
des manifestations et dans la rue mais
aussi les manifestations de
mécontentement qui a déjà obligé le
gouvernement à changer de posture
puisque c'est tout de même sur la
méthode c'est tout à fait curieux que au
fil du temps les positions changent on
revient sur ce qu'on a dit jeu au mois
d'avril le président de la république
indiqué que les 64 ans c'était
impossible de revenir là dessus et puis
vous avez vu ces déclarations disons
qu'après tout 64 ans n'est pas forcément
la meilleure chose donc notre rôle à
nous c'est de montrer combien ça peut
engendrer d'injustice au delà des belles
déclarations que auquel personne ne
croit plus au gouvernement en général
manille la supercherie avec une
dextérité remarquable alors ça a marché
pendant un certain temps ça ne marche
plus et quand il nous dit que la réforme
des retraites par points ça va a été
l'amélioration on sent bien que derrière
ça il ya une volonté de faire des
économies alors qu'il n'y avait pas
besoin d'en faire meilleur sur ce que
dit jean paul delevoye le
haut-commissaire la réforme des
retraites un métier identique une
retraite identique à cotisations
identique une retraite identique ce
n'est pas ça la justice selon vous ça
veut dire que vous sacraliser les
inégalités de salaires voulait prolonger
pendant la retraite et vous ça veut dire
aussi que ceux qui vont vivre le moins
longtemps ceux qui ont une espérance de
vie de 10 ans qui vont pas profiter de
tout ce qu'ils ont cotisé vont payer
pour ceux qui sont les plus riches et
qui ont une espérance de vie beaucoup
plus longue c'est pas ça la justice très
bien merci beaucoup jean louis touraine
pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction ronan dantec je voudrais pour
conclure que l'on parle d'un sujet qui
n'a pas été à l'ordre du jour de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement d'ailleurs assez étonnant
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé des
échanges entre grethen berg et emmanuel
macron lui qui critiquent les marches
pour le climat elle qui attaque la
france pour son inaction climatique
c'est l'escaladé est ce que c'est utile
et on est bien obligé de constater qu'on
tient pas les engagements de l'accord de
paris ici en france personne ne les
tient un et que donc que greta thomert
qui je trouve fait preuve de beaucoup
d'intelligence dans ce qu'elle porte
dans le débat public je crois qu'elle
est beaucoup plus intelligent qu'un
certain nombre des commentaires qu'elle
reçoit en retour il y en a qui sont
absolument terrifiant qui n'est complet
de gens qui sans sentiments des gens
reconnus l'intelligencia française je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes disent
le compte n'y est pas et que donc ils
n'attendent pas des discours ils
attendent des résultats et les résultats
quantitatifs s'attend même pas un
chapelet d'action il attend des
résultats quantitatifs et
qu'effectivement dire à la france ben
désolé vous ne tenez pas à vos
engagements c'est vrai et que donc calé
qu'emmanuel macron que d'autres se
sentent interpellés un mois là à leur
place je le prendrais comme justement
une incitation à dire encore plus vous
déplorez la réaction d' emmanuel macron
qui trouvent qu'il se fait faire la
leçon on a entendu les réactions ce
matin du gouvernement qu'elle juge que
ce discours et les trop radical qu'il y
a même trop de haine par le discours de
greta tonnes dingue oui oui moi je pense
que je pense qu'il ya une
incompréhension et il ya notamment une
incompréhension politiques sur le fait
que les dernières projections de la
communauté scientifique comme l'institut
simon laplace qui est reconnu
internationalement
institut français qui disent peut-être
plus 7 degrés au 21ème siècle ça veut
dire que mes enfants mes petits enfants
à l'evo n'ont aucun avenir et que cette
colère de la jeunesse elle ne va pas
disparaître
elle ne disparaîtra que si on donne des
solutions réelles or ce gouvernement je
pense aujourd'hui à une difficulté et
c'est toutes vos questions
qui est qu' il manque 40 milliards
d'investissements publics et privés par
an on pouvait lire que la france ses
objectifs sur le climat c'est totalement
contraire avec cette orthodoxie dont on
parle depuis
le dé lyon démission il faut trouver de
l'argent il faut remettre de l'argent et
cet argent doit être aussi un mac un
moyen de créer de l'emploi de la
cohésion sociale les deux vont ensemble
effectivement ce gouvernement n'a pas
décidé d'aller dans ce sens même si un
discours fort incarné par le président
sur la question-clé d'air que vous aviez
travaillé sur un rapport sur la france
en 2050 et son adaptation dérèglement
climatique donc vous savez vie qui
confectionneront revient sur ce point et
on voit bien aussi et je crois que c'est
une autre question à tous ces seuils ne
pas être trop politicien dans dans mes
interventions mais il faut construire un
contrat un déséquilibre de cours moyen
terme entre les intérêts des uns et des
autres pour faire évoluer la société la
question de l'eau il y avait une
question cet après midi là dessus et au
centre la question des pesticides
il y avait aussi une question est au
centre et là je n'étais pas d'accord
avec manuel wargon parce que quand elle
dit que 20% finalement des surfaces dont
elles perdent non il suffit de les
passer en bio donc là on voit bien qu'il
ya des logiciels qui ont du mal à bouger
et oui on peut bouger ça sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
mes questions merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette émission à 18h30 ne manquez pas
allant plus loin la nouvelle émission de
rebecca fitoussi au programme ce soir le
débat sur la pma vue du sénat bonne
soirée on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour de nouvelles questions
d'actifs
[Musique]